these two party together as much as they
work together after they responded
leaving tape nightclub at 6am yesterday
RiRi and Rosie were at it again last
night in London they were caught on
camera leaving [ __ ] nightclub doing
their entrance and exits separately this
of course was after Drake made another
surprise appearance on stage during
Rihanna's anti tour stop in Manchester
where they got up close and personal
performing work you gotta make some
noise for the most beautiful talented
women I've ever saw but it wasn't just
their chemistry that captured people's
attention I just want to welcome you
guys the anti ones who are residents
living near the outdoor concert venue
claimed they could hear the noise 10
miles away Manchester Evening News
obtained this audio recorded by a
resident who was inside their home with
the windows closed and another resident
tweeted Rihanna you're awful concert
disturb most of Manchester tonight not
all of us want to be kept awake by know
as you create hashtag nuisance but Danny
actually saw it as a good thing feel
sorry for anyone who is paid for Rihanna
concert tickets I'm in my garden singing
away it's that loud and Shane had the
best tweet of all laughing about all the
people who can't sleep because rihanna's
concert is so loud doesn't she realize
people have to work where at where at
where quick harrietta did please a lot
of people who stood in line in the rain
for a concert she said towels and 20
boxes of pizza to the Rihanna Navy and
for another added treat she premiered
her new video for sledgehammer her song
from Star Trek beyond
break and I'm I said damn